ああ
うそいやいやいや
[音楽]
これじゃあ聡社長です皆さん全部ショットってしますか
本当に鉄球とかをここに置いてこうやってサービスになるのって
打つんですけど
マッチ棒をつけられないかなと思ってまぁ坪町もつけたいんですよほかっこいいから
結構威力が必要である
吐くときはもうすぐ着きますでいえどちょっとの3ショットを使ってね江東区から遠
距離でこれを付けれねーかと思いましたこれで今回は3ds ぐショットで遠くに
マッチ棒を置いてそれをこの3んぐショット町ぼぼくだけに腐って売ってバーンうっ
だけのこの過程でマッチ部を買っていれば坪のここをなんとか朝したマッチモード箱で
行こう切って気に
つってしたああっ
気が付くと奇跡を今日は起こす溝と思ういやちょっとねスリングショット上手くなりた
いってねとそういうことによっているも島人もに手が届かなかった時もことじゃね動か
ずに遠くからね
こうするだけでもう気がつけられるというこの時
私はまだ知らなかったん
事の重大さを
前
[音楽]
ん
いいえ
ます
[音楽]
ブーツまでやってます狙ってるよ
ですもうスレくらいですよ
あああ
goo
me
[音楽]
ca
6動く分月の福井つです6弦一弦してないんでかなり低いがくれるんですよ
ua ワード薄かった
クラーが振れて語ったの人数がつかなそうだったので裏でしっかり固定してやります
子様が絶対ブレない分でこれが支えつけられます
あーいけるですね
[音楽]
ますうわぁああそうだった
ダガー
[音楽]
ua 完全だったりは完全にクリーンヒットしません
うわぁ
[音楽]
あ
ua
今じゃちょっとあれ作ったよねー子年そうに下がってて気がするからちょっと遅い
コーベット大好き
tee
[音楽]
風圧でおっ
2分
ちょっと暗い奴は黙ってついてもする本当に良いプレーしてるん
[音楽]
そんなことあるそんな
矢次するっていうあああああっはぁ
[音楽]
th
voodoo
図2時間やっても付きませんこれさん作るのは本当に僕で作らどうかすら怪しいレベル
ですよ
えっ
[音楽]
ああああああああ
持っています
うわぁ
というわけで非常に悔しいんですけども12時間やったところすみませんでしたさすが
にいちいち中これをやってるわけにもいかないんですけどもう確率的にはほぼ0に近い
ことが分かりましたこれもまた一つの発見でしょう
スリングショットでマッチ棒はつけられま
全部たんでなんで改造したらできると思うんですよ例えばボールでそのボールが全部
やすいになってるとか
風の抵抗もあるし一面にしかついてないから
確率で当たる部分があるので確率的にはちょっと21日では叩きだせない数字でした
技いつか
リレーしまーす10時間返してっ
[音楽]
me
ni
me あった